[Musique]
deuxième jour de visite du ministre de
l'éducation nationale et de la jeunesse
au collège Henri Matisse de la Ravine
des Cabris pour signer les conventions
citées avec Saint-Pierre Saint Louis et
le tampon alors les cités éducatives
elles ont une grande originalité c'est
qu'elle rassemble des acteurs différents
autour d'une mission principale c'est
faire réussir nos élèves du scolaire du
périscolaire l'état bien sûr avec
l'Éducation nationale et le ministère de
la ville mais aussi les collectivités
vous avez vu des municipalités le
Conseil Général bref il s'agit de
rassembler des acteurs qui parfois
travaillent un petit peu en silo pour
les faire travailler ensemble dans le
scolaire dans le périscolaire et dans
l'extras scolaire et puis pour assurer
aussi la meilleure continuité éducative
entre le primaire le secondaire la
classe de 6e est particulièrement
importante la classe de secondes aussi
l'entrée à l'école l'entrée en
maternelle tout cela peut être facilité
par les cités éducatives à travers ce
projet de cité éducative 3 cités
éducatives tampon Saint-Pierre
Saint-Louis le souhait du président du
Département que je suis c'est le pouvoir
déployer ce dispositif sur l'ensemble de
la réunion nous voulons faire de la
Réunion un territoire à défi éducatif
trois nouvelles cités éducatives qui
viennent s'adoudre précédente
labellisation des villes du port et de
Saint-Benoît
[Musique]